- Welcome everyone to a new coffee break,
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, I'm a
former McKinsey consultant.
Today, I will talk about one
of the most common mistakes
that young leaders, young professionals,
people working in consulting,
also in industry are doing.
It's a mistake that many people confuse
with having been the victim
of corporate politics.
But no, if this happens to you,
it's not due to politics, but it's on you.
It's a mistake that you made.
And trust, it is going to be juicy
and extremely relevant
for every young professional out there.
So in this fictive scenario,
there was a team lead
who worked on an important new initiative
over the last weeks.
Now there's this meeting
where this person's presenting
the progress and also the way forward
on his or her initiatives
to the senior leaders of the organization.
But now what happens?
These senior leaders actually
criticize the approach.
They do not agree with
the proposed action plans.
what is being presented
to them at this point in time.
And indeed, due to this, the
whole meeting is derailed,
and, of course, also the reputation
of the person presenting this will suffer.
Their standing will take a hit.
So does this sound familiar?
Think about it, what went wrong?
Could the person have done
something to prevent this?
And I want really to
literally stop the video now,
just read through this
and reflect on that.
What is your opinion on this?
Could this person have
done something differently
to shape this meeting in a way
to lead to a better outcome?
So let's get into it.
What could this person have done?
And to better understand
that, I first want to look
into the typical process
that a typical team lead
in such a situation
will likely go through.
And indeed, this process
consists of three steps.
So first, that person
will conduct analysis
and derive results often
together with the team
to then get to something
that can be presented.
And indeed, this is then the second step.
Prepare a presentation, prepare
slides, prepare a document.
And then of course, in the end,
there's the presentation itself,
where the pages are being presented
and are being discussed in the meeting.
So let's go here step by step.
Step number one, what happened here?
Well, of course, often
information has been gathered
by colleagues, other sources,
maybe some expert interviews
that this person will have conducted.
You do this together with the team,
and then you derive the results together
with your colleagues
on the topics at hand.
Second step, where you
structure then all the analysis
into some type of presentation document.
Of course, hopefully, you apply the good
slide writing principles, the
top communication techniques,
top-down communication,
per every principle
that we talk about so
frequently here on this channel.
If all of this says nothing
to you, I will link a playlist
above here where you will read
about more of these topics,
watch videos on exactly this.
Last, but not least,
there's a presentation.
Of course, often the
team lead will deliver
this presentation him or herself
in front of the senior
leadership of the organization.
And now, once again,
I want you to pause the
video and think about that.
Thinking about this approach,
will this likely be successful?
Will this likely lead to a good result?
In my humble opinion, in my experiences,
no, this will not work, right,
because what is the problem?
If you do this, this process often leads
to negative outcomes
as also shared in the
initial example, why?
Because the team lead did not
manage to align the results
with all the key stakeholders
of the organization.
Alignment, one of the
most important topics
in every big corporate,
in consulting for sure.
It is a topic so common,
so important in consulting
that it is literally a meme.
Here my friends @ConsultingHumor
prepared this little quote,
"Just had a meeting to
align on how we will align
with the client during our
weekly alignment meeting."
Right, alignment, alignment,
alignment, alignment.
You will have lots of meetings every week,
just to align content.
By the way, Consulting Humor,
really a great channel
for humor like this.
I will link the socials below
in the video description.
Check it out, great
content, I can promise you.
But why is it so important
to align content,
to align documents before meetings?
Let's go over some typical
problems that arise
if you do not do this,
if alignment is missing.
Well first, of course,
colleagues will likely not have
any buy-in in the
solution that you present
as they were not involved
in the solution process.
Next point, valid concerns were not heard
and reflected in the solution.
Maybe there were really
some important things
that the senior leaders of
your organization were aware of
that you just couldn't be aware of.
But of course, now you don't know
because you didn't involve them.
You didn't align your solutions
to your contents with them.
Next, there's the natural
tendency to defend the status quo
and think about the reasons
why proposed change is bad.
If you just propose something new,
something that will change the status quo,
and someone just hears
it for the first time,
likely their very first reaction will be,
"Ah, nah, probably not.
Probably we don't need to do that."
Next point, very much related to that.
No one likes to be surprised,
especially not in front
of their colleagues.
If you walk into meeting and
suddenly you hear something,
see something that is
very surprising to you,
that you did not expect at all.
Ah, that's likely not great.
And especially if then your
other senior colleagues
are sitting next to you because
this also just makes you
look uninformed, unaware
of what is going on
in your organization,
especially if this was
your direct superior and
that person didn't even know
what you were thinking about,
what you were working on.
That's just bad because this also
makes that person look bad.
Next point, it's also just very generally
considered unprofessional.
You will be expected that you
will have aligned key results
with all the key stakeholders,
even if maybe the people
did not directly task you to do that.
That's just an expectation
towards the role
of a team lead in such an organization.
And as I said in the beginning,
many people confused these types
of reactions with politics.
"Oh, that person didn't like me.
That person had something against me.
That person didn't want me to succeed."
Right, and pretty much blame it
on the culture of the organization.
This is not what's going on.
You are hiding yourself from the truth.
It was your responsibility.
It is your responsibility to
make sure that these types
of alignment errors don't happen.
But let's now discuss what
this team lead could have done
to properly align the results,
the contents of the work
with the senior leaders,
with the stakeholders.
How could the person
have improved the outcome
of this important meeting?
And by the way, before we do it,
if you took any value out
of this video at all so far,
please hit the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
Of course, also subscribe,
turn on the notification bell
to stay up to date with all of my content.
This is very, very much appreciated.
But let's look at it step by step.
For all the three steps
you initially outline
and start with the first
one, to conduct an analysis
and derive results.
And here the mistake that many people do
is that they see their
colleagues, also their clients,
just as some data sources.
If you just walk around the organization,
just request information from people,
then for you to do the
analysis and to do the work,
well of course, you do
need all this information.
This is not to be confused
with properly co-creating
solutions with the relevant colleagues.
So if you're leading such an initiative,
very clearly think about
what the people are
that you want the buy-in from.
Think about some
appropriate workshop formats
or other good ways to
directly involve them
also in the process to make
sure that they feel like
they have been part of the solution,
that they feel like it
was maybe even their idea
what you proposed in the end.
This often goes a long way.
Next, never, never,
never walk into a meeting
with your senior leaders and
letting them see the document
the first time.
But what I mean is that you
properly take the time to,
in the one or two weeks before
this very important meeting,
you meet with all these
people, one on one,
and you guide them through the document.
If it's not the final document
because it's not ready yet,
then at least the rough
outline, the key results
that you want to share and you
ask them for their feedback,
you ask them for their guidance.
And this is, of course,
especially important
also in consulting and
potentially especially challenging
in consulting because then
not only you need to align
the documents with your clients,
but you also need to align
all the key documents
with your internal leadership.
And this can be quite challenging
because often you end up
going in circles, right?
So you create a document,
align it with a client.
Then you take the document,
show it to your partner
and actually your partner disagrees.
The partner think, "No, this
is not what you can do."
So you turn around the document,
then you go back with this
document to the client,
and then the client says,
"No, I disagree", right?
And then this can go really in circle.
So that's often quite a pain,
especially as a project lead
to moderate all this.
And then last, but not least,
for this presentation in
front of the senior leaders,
very carefully think about whether
you are really the best
person to present it.
And of course, I understand
that maybe you'll think,
"Oh, it would be great for
myself to get this visibility,
get this spotlight,
present in front of all
these senior leaders."
But sometimes, it might make more sense
for potentially a person more
senior than you to present it.
This is actually even more
important than in-professional
services where you often
usually try that the clients
are actually presenting the results
of your project, of your work.
It's always so much more convincing, too.
For instance, the board of
management of a large company
to see that the results
are not being presented
by external consultants, but
internally by the team leads
of their own organization,
because this then
also to the board shows that this is not
just the crazy consulting idea,
which afterwards people are
just throwing in the bin,
but this is something that
their own organization
really buys into it.
But now let me know
about your experiences,
any crazy anecdotes you
can share on aligning
or actually not aligning
things in the proper way.
Let me know in the comments.
Also, if you have any other
tips on these types of topics.
Of course, as always big, big thanks
to all the members of the channel.
Thanks for the support,
very much appreciated.
My name is Heinrich, I
release weekly videos
here on the channel,
see you again next week.
Until then, all the
best to you and bye bye.